ich kann
abend
freue mich riesig
sie warfen
du willst du dir danke schön dass wir
vom stammtisch und kerzen gekommen
auf diesen zu hause ja ich finde es top
dass so viele leute hier in süd gekommen
sind auch passend zum philosophischen
stammtisch einen flop hingegen fand ich
meine bahnreisen hierhin denn der zug
verspätet und wieso mit meinem health
chor steht weiß ich auch nicht ich war
nämlich kürzlich erkältet willkommen in
der ratinggesellschaft in der
ratinggesellschaft bewerten kunden die
verkäufer patienten die ärzte mieter
ihre vermieter und selbst beim dating
kann mittlerweile sternchen scores und
ratings zum einsatz
wie gesund liebe ich früher konnte die
frage allenfalls ein arzt beantworten
heute suggeriert der blick aufs handy
vermeintliche antwort in sachen
gesundheit verbrannte kalorien
zurückgelegte strecke und absolvierte
kilometer
jeder tag steht in konkurrenz zum
nächsten 10.000 schritte pro tag sind
gleichsam pflicht
verschiedene krankenkassen unterstützen
diesen trend bieten prämien
vergünstigungen für gesundheitsbewusste
an dass ihre kunden nebenbei viele daten
über sich preisgeben ist teil des spiels
doch nicht nur die eigene leistung wird
rund um die uhr bewertet heutzutage
wollen selbst kantinen von ihren kunden
wissen wie sie den service empfinden
ob es geschmeckt und gefallen hat
sogar bäckereien bitten schon um
digitales feedback ob die leistung der
bedienung zufriedenstellend war und auch
museen scheint es brennend zu
interessieren was ihre besucher von
ihrer ausstellung halten
auf plattformen wie toni können sich die
teilnehmer gegenseitig anonym bewerten
der weg zum cybermobbing ist nicht mehr
weit bereits selbstverständlich ist es
bei hotel oder restaurant anbietern auf
die bewertungen zu gucken
dabei garantiert niemand dass diese
bewertungen auch echt sind
top oder flop
in unserer digitalisierten welt ist es
selbstverständlich geworden dinge
dienstleistungen ja menschen zu bewerten
die frage ist nur wo führt das hin
ja und ich bin sehr gespannt auf die
diskussion begrüßen sie ganz herzlich
mit mir unsere stammgäste
es sind dies katja gentinetta politik
philosophin aus lenzburg
konrad paul liessmann professor für
philosophie ausliegen
und das ist auch heute armin us
soziologe professor für soziologie aus
münchen herzlich willkommen
ja herr diesmal wir haben es gerade
gesehen unsere meinung ist gefragt wie
nie zuvor
erfolg wir uns eigentlich noch
schleichen ganz im gegenteil schon hegel
hat mal bemerkt das beste was man von
einer meinung sagen kann ist dass man
sie für sich behalten kann
das heißt also eine welt die welt wäre
sicher besser werden die menschen ihre
meinungen ganz ganz für sich behalten
würden ethnologisch falscher nicht
unwitzig hat täglich gesagt wäre es
anders würde man nicht von meinung
sondern von teilung sprechen
das heißt die meinung bleibt bei uns und
alles andere verhandeln wir dann wie
vernünftige menschen dinge aushandeln
jetzt sind meinungen über abgefragt und
jeder tut seine meinung jederzeit und
überall kunden und das ist glaube ich
nicht etwas was uns unbedingt freuen
muss aber grundsätzlich kann man ja mal
sagen die transparenz nimmt zu also und
könnte sagen na ja der kunde ist könig
der kriegt jetzt mehr material frau
zentimeter das wäre doch eigentlich ganz
im sinne eben der transparenz und der
kundeninformation wenn ich den
informationen denn trauen könnte und das
glaube ich ja nicht immer das davor die
ja auch gesagt ich mein ich weiß bei
vielen diesen bewertungen nicht was
steckt wirklich dahinter sind die punkte
wirklich so gesetzt wie viele leute
haben punkte gesetzt haben die leute
punkte gesetzt wie sie wirklich meinen
oder wurden sie gebeten die punkte so zu
setzen dass ihr wert eine vermeintliche
objektivität aufgetischt die ich als
solcher einfach nicht beurteilen kann
und ich bin deshalb sehr skeptisch
gegenüber diesen rating sich beachten
sie auch kaum und auch wenn ich
aufgefordert werde bin ich eigentlich
froh heißt es leben daran noch später
drücke ich immer später lieber nicht wir
zeigen wie steigen ja na ja es ist ein
zweischneidiges schwert bewertet wurde
eigentlich immer und man konnte auch
eigentlich nie genau sagen ob diese
bewertung wirklich stimmt also es waren
zb oftmals leute die ihr die möglichkeit
hatten zu bewerten als andere
man könnte ja wenn man naiv es hingehen
und sagen jetzt sind es offenbar mehr
leute die das tun und vielleicht ist ja
durch spielt ja etwas was mehr ist als
nur die individuelle meinung ob das nun
tatsächlich um es auch philosophisch zu
sagen mit kant zwischen sagen wir mal
wissen
augen und meinen sozusagen etwas ist von
allem das weiß man nicht genau
aber es ist schon so dass inzwischen
mehr leute bewerten und das könnte ja
zumindest die bewertung verändern
ob sie verbessert dass es noch die frage
nun ist natürlich auch die
digitalisierung ein wichtiger aspekt in
diesem ganzen in die ranzen debatte über
die reichen gesellschaft steffen bau der
soziologe der dieses buch geschrieben
hat das metrische wir dazu haben wir
auch einen artikel auf unserer plattform
auf unserer website der sagt im grunde
genommen es wurde genau wie sie gesagt
haben immer schon bewertet aber dank der
digitalisierung oder wegen der
digitalisierung gibt es jetzt so
unglaublich viele daten dass das ganz
neue dimensionen annimmt
es ist genau der punkt also früher hatte
man natürlich seine meinungen man
behielt sie entweder für sich oder
verbreitete sie im kleinen kreis in der
familie im freundeskreis am stammtisch
ja durch die digitalisierung ist es
möglich geworden dass dann tatsächlich
publik zu machen öffentlich zu machen
am besten gleich der ganzen welt
zugänglich zu machen das heißt die ganze
welt zu überschütten mit seinen
meinungen
das mag auf der einen seite dazu führen
dass wir jetzt andere dimensionen des
bewerbers und des wartens haben
auf der anderen seite liegt im wesen von
meinungen das sie kurz ihn unmittelbar
sinn effektiv sind dieser meinung ist
sie nicht begründet dass wir immer
sondern das unterscheidungsmerkmal
zwischen meinung und argumente etwa
funktioniert deswegen ist das symbol ja
auch sinnfällig nach dem prinzip der
antiken gladiatoren spieler daumen rauf
daumen runter unmittelbar das gibt
stimmungsbilder wieder auf die muss man
und kann man natürlich auch reagieren
aber es ziehen sozusagen in dem sinne
keine wertungen eine im sinne jetzt
eines reflektierten bergens ja und diese
form von massenhaft erzeugter
emotionaler unmittelbarkeit ist etwas
das einerseits interessant ist auf der
anderen seite aber denke ich durchaus
auch anders sein kann so ein bisschen
kritisch darüber nachzudenken und wenn
diese wertungen dann in richtung
entgehen die unseren politischen oder
moralischen vorstellungen widersprechen
ohne ihn sofort alle etwas dagegen dass
jeder die möglichkeit hat auf der social
media sofort in dem was er ein feld das
reihum und um die ganze welt zu posten
das sind ja auch vorne von belästigungen
ständig konfrontiert zu werden mit den
meinungen anderer menschen beschützt
mich davor
sie können selbst entscheiden ob sie
sich anschauen oder nicht ist kann ja
nicht immer denn man besucht die und
welche webseiten oder in der
informationsdienste möchte nur eine
information und wird zugeschüttet
wir haben recht ausbleiben das ist eine
aktivität dann muss man dann wieder
hinten und das kostet wieder zeit und
lebenszeit es klappt das hier ist ein
ich bin ja eigentlich ganz einfach sein
ich würde es wird sogar noch einen
schritt weiter gehen es gibt ja wirklich
in der philosophie die klassische
diskussion eine bewertung ein wert ist
der inneren gegeben ist er objektiv
vorhanden oder kommt er einfach zustande
indem wir uns dazu einig werden dass wir
etwas so bewerten und wenn wir diesem
engeren bewertungen ab schauen dann geht
das erste eigentlich komplett verloren
und darin sehe ich eigentlich fast die
größte gefahr dass nur noch die
übereinkunft übrig bleibt die zufällige
wie sie richtig sagen emotionale
augenblickliche übereinkunft von sehr
vielen von denen ich aber nicht weiß auf
welche kriterien sie sich stützen ob sie
dieselben haben
ob ich diese kriterien teile und so
weiter und sagen es bleibt einfach
sozusagen eine globale leben übrig die
ein beispiel meinen sie so was wie ich
bin jetzt zum beispiel jemand ich mag
eine minibar
aber wenn ich mir tripadvisor angucke
und die ratings oder überhaupt sternchen
vergabe dann ist zum beispiel das
vorhandensein einer minibar oder eines
wellness bereichs wichtig mir ist sehr
viel wichtiger dass das hotel einfach
ruhig ist und eigentlich relativ basic
ausgerüstet ist würden sie so was meinen
sie haben will sozusagen nur noch die
hotels hoch gerät sitzt die eben diesen
kriterien die vorgegeben sind
entsprechen ganz genau weil es sich ja
vorgegeben was ich retten kann ich kann
dann immer noch einen kommentar geben
aber wer schaut die ganzen kommentare an
und eben noch mal sind die kommentare
ehrlich gemeint oder sind sie eher beten
dann sind sie sogar kommerzialisiert
also darf sicher ein interessanter punkt
man weiß ja dass eben ganz viel davon
gefälscht ist es gibt ganze firmen ich
habe mir eine angeguckt die heißt
faistauer marketing die verkauft jeden
monat tausende von bewertungen und
beschäftigt
jahrtausend kommentar schreiben de da
kann man wirklich zur praxis kaufen
likes und sternchen was ich noch alles
da gibt es auch verschiedene tests die
gemacht wurden was eigentlich passiert
wenn ein restaurant sich da eben
sternchen einkauft oder likes einkauft
wie schnell das restaurant dann eben
auch wirklich nachgefragt wird weil es
zum beispiel dann plötzlich im lonely
planet erscheint aber wenn das so ist
warum vertrauen dir den trotzdem ich
weiß nicht ob wir dem vertrauen sondern
solche dinge die entstehen ja quasi von
selbst und vor allem reflexion frei das
spannende ist ja dass solche bewertungen
so eine anmutung von objektivität haben
und das spielen ja die zahlen eine ganz
bestimmte rolle also wenn man sagt 97,3
prozent der gäste fanden das essen gut
aber 23,4 prozent fanden die toilette
nicht so toll und von mir aus haben noch
14,7 irgendwas anderes und manche haben
die fünf prozent hürde nicht genommen
was auch immer das heißt das hört sich
an wie eine objektive anmutung und das
ist das spannende eigentlich an den
zahlen
das ist eben was anderes als eine reine
meinung also ich kann davon berichten
ich habe da gegessen und fand den
tintenfisch ganz gut aber das
rindfleisch war trocken ist was anderes
als wenn ich eine quasi für
objektivierte form lese und das
verändert die dinge natürlich schon und
wir wissen von jeder bewertungs
dimension dass unser verhalten sich
irgendwann den bewertungs dimensionen an
passt also wenn ich nur besser werden
kann indem ich sozusagen die kriterien
verbessere nach denen die bewertungs
dimension läuft dann werde ich das
verhalten entsprechend ändern ich finde
du jetzt die hotels mit den minibars am
besten dass wir uns da nicht einig aber
diesen punkt den sie jetzt gerade
erwähnt haben dass ich ja sozusagen die
angst vor konformismus dass man sagt
naja dieses ganze rating führt dazu dass
wir plötzlich nicht mehr diese
diversität haben sondern alle richten
sich eben aus nach den gleichen
kriterien bei uns nicht der fall aber
grundsätzlich ist das eine
eine befürchtung die wir ernst nehmen
müssen angst vor konformismus
ich weiß es nicht ich glaube es im
prinzip eigentlich nicht werde ich denke
dass menschen als individuellen
zwar sich hier beeinflussen lassen
können
aber ich merke auch an mir sehen war
dass diese beeinflussung nicht wirklich
rasend weit geht
denn wäre es der fall wir spielen ja
dieses spiel der ratings und bewertungen
in verschiedenen branchen und bereichen
ja schon etliche jahre sich safin von
gestern ja wäre das der fall würde das
bedeuten dass durch diese bewertungen
und durch diese kriterien und wenn die
objektiv werden in den letzten jahren
alle ärzte besser hätten werden müssen
alle restaurants besser hätten werden
müssen alle hotels besser hätten werden
müssen alle rechtsanwälte hätten besser
werden müssen allen lehrer hätten besser
wir müssen alle professor annette besser
werden ich habe jetzt nicht wahnsinnig
den eindruck dass alles besser wird
sondern offensichtlich ist das was als
durchschnittswert dann rauskommt und
wiederum so durchschnittlich dass ich da
so drumherum sozusagen alle unterschiede
durch ausprobieren können weil der eine
will eher ruhiges zimmer und der andere
braucht unbedingt die mienen bei der
eine will ein arzt der empathische auf
ihn zugeht und der andere will einfach
sozusagen einen handwerker war der ein
möglichst schnell repariert das heißt
das geht ja auch in die wertungen ein
das heißt die neutralisieren sie auf der
einen seite zum teil gegenseitig und auf
der anderen seite denke ich was sie
vorher angedeutet haben ist das auch
ganz interessant also sagen auf der
anderen seite frage ich mich immer wer
sind eigentlich die menschen die hier
bewerten ich zum beispiel kenne
niemanden der bewertet ich kenne viele
die die bewertungen lesen
das heißt es ist schon ein bestimmter
charakter von nöten um seiten lang zu
bewerten und diese kritiken auf einmal
so ne moment beschreiben
restaurants wie die toiletten weil sie
können nie auf die idee eine halbe seite
zu schreiben wie toiletten in einem
restaurant seerhein gibt menschen die
wollen dass die tu was der verein kann
nichts anderes zu tun und wie
vertrauenswürdig sind eine solche
bewertung das ist der punkt wir haben
eine bewertung ist ja auch schon nur zu
sagen like oder eben diesen button nicht
zu drücken jetzt sind sie nicht auf
facebook zb ja aber ich bin mir ganz
sicher ganz viele hier drinnen sind auf
facebook oder instagram natürlich leicht
man das ist auch eine form von bewertung
sie wollten etwas an deutschen den ich
wollte sagen ebens bewerten was ich vor
allem die zeit haben und da liegt da
liegt ein gewisses problem da nochmal
der konformismus ich glaube der
konformismus ist schon das eine das dass
man sich danach richtet das andere aber
ist und das zeigen das zeigen ja ganz
viele entwicklungen wird die zeit leute
entscheiden sich auch das gegenteil zu
machen oder eine nische zu suchen oder
genau einen anderen wert hoch zu schauen
es ist ja nicht so dass alle nur nach
rennen ist produziert ja in der menge
genau gleich wieder auch gegenbewegungen
und das finde ich aber transparenz gut
je mehr wir sehen desto mehr wissen wir
auch okay es gibt eigentlich auch noch
was anderes als wir müssen nicht nur den
wenigen bewertungen folgen die es gibt
wenn ich daran denke an mischler
restaurants das war bekannt wie viel da
geschmiert wurde um dann hohes rating zu
bekommt das ging auch nicht nur objektiv
zu das ist nichts neues
ich würde gerne noch eine stufe tiefer
ansetzen weil die bewährten jetzt
sozusagen schon das bewerten aber man
könnte ja erst auch einmal sagen
bewährten an sich ist menschlich das ist
doch etwas was mir sowieso dauernd tun
und wie gesagt wir haben es immer schon
getan
wenn sie jetzt aber so kritisch sind und
sie alle drei sind glaube ich relativ
kritisch miteinander sagen dann
kritisieren sie eigentlich ein
menschliches bedürfnis nein nein ich
bewerten ob wir bewerten ja ständig
selber jede entscheidung die wir fällen
ist eine bewertung zwischen zwei dingen
die wir anders bewerten das müssen wir
machen jede entscheidung ist ein
ausdruck von präferenzen das tun wir
aber die frage ist muss ich das überall
kultur oder kann ich einfach eine
bewertung für mich fällen und die
entscheidenden stellen und das für mich
behalten das ist der unterschied
das in der tat der unterschied aber mir
wäre es zu wenig sozusagen jetzt nur
nach dem bewertenden zu fragen sondern
es ist ja ganz spannend zu sehen dass
wir in offenbarten kulturelles phänomen
haben dass diese
wertungen eine rolle spielen und ich
glaube die phänomene die wir so deutlich
sehen das sind eigentlich nur
oberflächen phänomene was wir zurzeit
beobachten und so haben das bis jetzt
eigentlich nur diskutiert ist so was wie
ein durchschnitt in umoja hat man
sozusagen versucht rauszukriegen
durchschnittsmenschen aber solche
datensätze dienen schon dazu sehr
direktes marketing zu machen zu sehen
also wenn wir zb ein dissens darüber
hätten ob der wellnessbereich oder die
minibar wichtiger wäre dann wäre schon
interessant aus daten zu matchen wem man
eigentlich marketing gegenüber macht der
bestimmte kombinationen und
rekombination von bestimmten
informationen verwendet also dass wir
selber bewerten und her ließ man sie
haben das ja gerade sehr eindrucksvoll
dargestellt dass dazu auch eine
merkwürdige charakter womöglich gehört
aber die meisten daten die verwendet
werden werden gar nicht sozusagen über
so ein button gemacht sondern das sind
datensätze die gewissermaßen sondern
digitalisierten welt ohnehin anfallen
und dann haben wir mit big data
tatsächlich datensätze die eigentlich
nicht dafür erhoben worden sind
miteinander gemischt zu werden sie
werden aber gemischt und dann kann man
ganz gezielt sagen dass man bewertungen
hat die sozusagen in der kombination
ganz bestimmte produkte und
dienstleistungen für einen markt
wahrscheinlicher und wertiger machen das
andere würde ich fast sagen ist eine art
naja fähiges übertrieben aber es ist ein
schönes spiel bei dem wir so tun als
würden wir über unsere bewertungen
selbst die dinge besser machen
eigentlich werden sie besser gemacht
dadurch dass dahinter eine technik
steckt die völlig anders funktioniert
als sie uns eigentlich
selbstverständlich sein sagt wir
bewerten immer in der tat aber heute
bewerten tatsächlich statistische
programme im hinblick auf
marktgängigkeit von produkten und
dienstleistung wird gerne mal eine
schulklasse zu wort kommen lassen die
nämlich hierauf zu gast ist das ist eine
autoritäts klasse aus münchenstein und
diese schüler und schülerinnen sind hier
bei uns zu gast und von ihnen sie sind
ja doch um einiges jünger jetzt als wir
hier am tisch würde ich doch gerne mal
wissen wie es denn bei ihnen so aussieht
nutzen sie solche instrumente machen sie
so schreckliche dinge wie verließ man
gerade beschriebene also ich war mal auf
facebook aktiv aber jetzt nicht mehr
weil ich mich einfach dazu entschieden
habe anonym zu bleiben und ich möchte
nicht zb aufgrund meines
aussehens bewertet werden aber zum
beispiel wenn sie in urlaub fahren
nutzen sie auch schrittweise und
vertrauen sie diesen kommentaren mache
ich nicht nein
das erstaunt mich jetzt ein bisschen
ließ es bei ihnen ich bin auf facebook
aktiv was form auch mit meiner familie
in engem kontakt zu behalten
aber ich folge auch meinen hobbys und
die hier am anderen teams die dann
hobbys zu tun haben und bin auch auf
tripadvisor sehe ich mir die kommentare
auch an
jetzt hat man ja immer mal wieder likes
sind heute sozusagen die währung die
soziale währung in mikes drückt sich aus
ob man gerade in ist man gut aussieht wo
man gerade was gepostet hat das
interessant ist empfinden sie das selber
so nein also ich denke es sei wichtig
sich eine eigene meinung zu machen und
ich bin mir auch sicher dass es wichtig
ist auch außerhalb der sozialen mädchen
sich ein leben noch zu gestalten
sie klingen alle so wahnsinnig
vernünftig dass er habe ich auch
erwartet
aber es ist ja trotzdem soll man hört
immer wieder auch von fällen ich meinen
cyber mobbing ist ein großes thema
jugendliche sind jetzt schon ein
bisschen älter junge erwachsene die
unglaublich leiden unter solchen
phänomenen ich weiß nicht kennen sie so
was man sich darüber gedanken
also ich benutze selbst auch solche
soziale medien aber ich bin auch eher
skeptisch darüber eingestellt weil ich
habe auch schon gemerkt dass durch diese
likes auf die man je nach dem viel wert
legt kann schon eine gewisse
unzufriedenheit hergestellt werden wenn
man nur noch darauf geht wenn ich etwas
poster oder ein profilbild von ihrer
stelle muss sich möglichst viele likes
dafür bekommen sonst kann ich nicht
eigentlich zufrieden sein und das finde
ich doch schon eher traurig wenn sich
das in diese richtung entwickelt und was
tun sie dagegen
ich brauche das nicht mehr so viel
[Gelächter]
eine art selbsttherapie bei ihnen habe
ich gesehen sie haben so ein baum von
fitness bands und sie bewerten sich
sozusagen selber also sie brauchen das
zum sport machen oder gucken sie auch
nicht geschlafen so ein weniger also es
ist für mich eher eine kontrolle
inwiefern ich meine sportliche
aktivitäten eigentlich sich verbessern
meine kondition auch verbessert aber
weniger um die den schlaf zu
kontrollieren ich selber habe ich jetzt
weniger mühe mit dem schlaf und somit
brauche ich diese verschiedenen
schlafphasen auch nicht zu kontrollieren
aber sie sind sozusagen im wettbewerb
mit sich selbst und versuchen sich zu
verbessern indem sie sich vermessen kann
man so nicht sehen dass halt ein
individuelles ziel von mir selber dass
ich jetzt speziell im konditionellen
bereich mich verbessern möchte weil ich
einen sportlichen hintergrund habe und
ich mich für sport interessieren und
demnach ist es sogar eine motivation
mich stetig in dem in diesem bereich zu
verbessern und vielen dank diese konnte
feick bewegung also mit diesen bändern
zu arbeiten die gehen ja zum teil noch
viel viel weiter man kann alles von sich
messen seinen blutdruck sinken schon
machen sie daher nach fähig ich mache
das nicht aber ich weiß dass das geht in
der tat und das ist natürlich in alles
ist ja ganz spannend was heißt
eigentlich alles also man kann
stimmungen zum beispiel auch messen und
zwar relativ indirekt dass das was ich
vorhin auch sagte dass wir datensätze
haben bei denen leute die etwas darüber
wissen wollen das tun können also habe
jetzt gerade über facebook gesprochen
meine licon gab es auch aus der zeit als
ich so jung war wie die jungen leute von
gerade das war in den 70er jahren da gab
es die ganzen apparate nicht gelegt
werden wollten wir auch von ganz
richtigen leuten mit denen wir uns
getroffen haben und die wir zum teil
auch nicht gesehen haben also sozusagen
die idee dass wir dass wir positiv
begutachtet werden wollen das gab es
schon vorher was wir jetzt natürlich
beobachten das ist das zum teil ein
anonymes geschehen ist was natürlich die
sache viel komplizierter macht und ich
wiederhole noch mal den gedanken dass
wir es auch mit einer form von bewertung
zu tun haben die wir selber gar nicht
mal kontrollieren können im hinblick
darauf was denn da eigentlich
bewertet wird und dass es agenturen gibt
die etwas tun wovon wir gar nicht wissen
was stattfinden wer heute von facebook
redet redet meistens von den praktiken
die wir so verwende ich bin sehr aktiv
auf facebook auf twitter übrigens auch
obwohl ich schon so alt bin aber es
spannend ist eigentlich daran viel mehr
was leute die ich nie zu gesicht
bekommen werde damit machen mit den
daten die dabei hinterlassen werden für
die es das licon vollkommen wurscht das
interessiert die überhaupt nicht was die
interessiert ist wie die rekombination
von bestimmten likes zu bestimmten
mustern führt cluster analysen nennt man
das in der statistik um damit etwas zu
machen also diese ratinggesellschaft ist
eigentlich eine die uns nur so zum spaß
mit retten lässt weil sie mit den
ratings fast ganz anderes was sind wir
dürfen bewährten derivaten mit daten
wir bezahlen mit daten und bezahlen wäre
sozusagen ja viel zu viel war das
hieraus voraussetzen würde dass wir
selber etwas tun mit meinen daten aber
wahrscheinlich schon eine ganze menge
gemacht ich habe sie aber noch nie
jemandem verkauft würde dem zustimmen
mit ausnahme eines lebens sei sehr zäh
sagte er ist facebook und twitter aktiv
obwohl also altis ich würde sagen weil
alles natürlich medien für alte menschen
wie wir wissen
donald trump berühmteste twitterer
dagegen zeit der gegenwart ist ja auch
kein ganz junger mehr und ich glaube
auch dass sozusagen mit unserer
generation auch diese medien wieder
verschwinden werden deswegen nicht
wundern dass überhaupt nicht dass die
jungen menschen ein lockeres und
vielleicht sogar enthaltsame verhältnis
zu diesen sozialen medien auch im stand
es hinauf zu bringen
aber eigentlich ist natürlich richtig
würde ihnen zustimmen
das ist nicht nur darum geht diese
suggestion zu erzeugen ich kann bewerten
und ich werde von menschen bewertet
sowie wir natürlich jeder will geliebt
werden jeder will anerkannt werden
gar keine frage sondern es geht schon
auch darum durch diese quantifizierung
mechanismen der digitalisierung mit sich
bringt diesen anscheinend von
objektivität zu erzeugen zahlen haben
eigentlich was unglaublich
faszinierendes ja das ist einfach so
zahlen werden immer mächtiger objektiver
verbindlicher als nur bestimmte worte an
das statistisch ausweisen kann hat das
ganzen anderen charakter und das andere
ist was sie wirklich wesentlich
interessanter ist und vielleicht auch
prekärer ist wie sie es gesagt haben die
datenspuren die wir hinterlassen wie
zusammengeführt werden um die wir dann
in verschiedenster art und weise
zurückgespielt bekommen
das kann manchmal ärgerlich sein das
kann man ganz beglückt sein einmal
sondern beispiel empfiehlt mir immer
meine eigenen bücher die ich geschrieben
habe und das finde ich wunderschön
das kann ich mir vorstelle es gibt dann
auch eine art light für einen selber ich
bin mir nicht so sicherlich gesagt ob
ihre analyse stimmt dass es gibt viele
zahlen die zeigen dass natürlich ganz
viele formen und sozialen medien extreme
zuwachsraten haben vielleicht jetzt
nicht facebook aber zum beispiel diese
ab die im ersten einspieler vorgestellt
wurde
anonym das ist eine ab die sehr sehr
stark wächst und da geht es wirklich nur
darum dass man einander anonym
eben so genannte tags schicken kann
nachrichten schicken kann
in denen man einfach irgendwelche
gerüchte verbreitet oder irgendwelche
meinungen mal kund tut also zum beispiel
auch ich habe mitgekriegt alle reden
übrigens über die schlecht oder du hast
deine neue frisur die sich einfach nur
schrecklich aus genau dazu dient das und
ganz ganz viele wirklich fast noch
kinder nutzen diese ab aber ich mein
geheimnis die jungen leute gehört und
ich finde was ich da interessant fand
dass wir schon sehr reflektiert damit
umgehen sie ist ja nicht einfach nur
locker unterhaltsam es ist reflektiert
sie überlegen ganz genau mache ich mit
ja oder nein was mache ich was mache ich
nicht mehr und warum mache ich das und
das finde ich interessant und deshalb
glaube ich neue apps natürlich haben die
zuwachsraten weise eben neu sind bis man
gelernt hat damit umzugehen also sucht
so viel zu dem optimismus der
gesellschaft dass die genaue lernt mit
solchen dingen umzugehen und was ich am
reflektieren eben interessant finde es
wirklich die tatsache dass wir zwar
bewerten aber dass jede bewertung an die
ich ja noch nicht ist ohne dass wir
wissen welche kriterien sind für uns
interessant und teile ich die kriterien
überhaupt das heißt ich brauche
eigentlich immer einen bezugsrahmen
und in dieser konnte in dieser endlosen
quantifizierung in dem masse von daten
gibt es eben wirklich leute individuen
die sagen ich mache das darum und das
mache ich deshalb nicht das heißt sie
überlegen sich welche kriterien sie für
sie wichtig sind und welche ziele und es
gibt diesen reflektierten umgang und den
würde ich nicht unterschätzen
vor allem nicht in der langen dauer also
ich bin ja nur ein soziologe das heißt
ich kann nicht so schön über die
individuellen reden die womöglich
vernünftig sind oder nicht sondern eher
über muster und daraus kann man ein
philosophisches argument machen dann
erkenntnistheoretische ich glaube
tatsächlich dass ich zurzeit etwas
radikales wandelt also dem die
klassische idee war eigentlich ob man
die wahrheit der welt erkennen kann wenn
man es ist schwierig das zu tun und wir
philosophen die sachen sagen uns dann
immer dass das nicht so einfach ist wie
man denkt aber wahrscheinlich ändert
sich zur zeit was ist heute eigentlich
eher so dass wir über mustererkennung so
etwas wie erkenntnis produzieren und
zwar überall in den wissenschaften in
den medien in der strafverfolgung in
marketing in den produktentwicklungen
und so weiter also muster erkennen und
würde bedeuten dass es gar nicht mehr
darum geht raus zu kriegen was in der
welt ist sondern über muster so etwas
wie völlig neue entitäten eigentlich
herzustellen und ich glaube dass die
bewertung die wir als einzelne machen ob
wir da mitmachen oder nicht mitmachen
gar nicht die frage ist also man könnte
ja sich vielleicht 250 oder 300 jahre
zurückversetzen und sagen die
bürgerliche idee von gewissen wie wir
sie kennen als seine als eine spur des
protestantismus oder wie auch immer man
das beschreiben will die haben wir ja
auch nicht gewählt da hätte man nicht
sagen können mit dem gewissen und so da
mache ich lieber nicht mit ich mache
lieber dieses katholische modell ethisch
von der hand in den mund zu legen und
wieder neu anzufangen selbst als
katholik der ich übrigens bin muss man
heute so protestantisch sein dass man
ein methodisches leben führt und eine
kontinuität herstellen
das kann ich nicht wählen das kann ich
auch nicht abwählen und ich glaube dass
wir in diesem muster erkennungs
geschichte weder wählen noch abwählen
können entscheidend ist die frage was
anständiges damit machen und das ist
tatsächlich die frage die so weit über
individuelle entscheidungen hinaus geht
sondern über fragen dass solche formen
der apps technologie das heißt der
erkenntnis der welt viel schwerer zu
kontrollieren sind zumindest nicht mit
den mitteln die wir jetzt politisch
kulturell und auch moralisch kennen
lassen sie uns noch einen punkt dazu
nehmen die vielleicht die ganze sache
doch noch ein bisschen zumindest
versucht dem was positives abzugewinnen
nämlich die frage wie erlangen wir
überhaupt einen status in einer
gesellschaft man könnte ja sagen na ja
früher hatte man die situation man war
eigentlich durch die geburt festgelegt
auf einen sozialen rang
man konnte nicht groß wählen und
diejenigen die sich hochgearbeitet
hatten das waren eigentlich sehr sehr
wenige heute könnte man sagen dann das
internet da gibts sowas für reputation
soziale reputation
man kann sich hocharbeiten indem man
eine gute idee hat man kann sternchen
sammeln like samen was weiß ich immer
und kann eigentlich da plötzlich dann in
erscheinung treten und da würde man doch
sagen diese hierarchie ist die bessere
reputation ist besser aber ich habe
einen verdacht
ja dann sagen und der vergleich geht in
die richtung dass diese form von jetzt
digital erzeugte reputation durch
rankings und ratings erzeugte reputation
für den einzelnen in etwa dieser
funktion hat wie die religion in der
gesellschaft ist beschrieben haben
ja es ist der trost für die armen
durchaus in wirklichkeit keine stellung
einer gesellschaft du wirst nicht
aufsteigen du lebst prekär aber du hast
ganz tolle bewertungen auf facebook sei
doch zufrieden damit
das ist sozusagen das was früher das
jenseits war du bist aber du wirst du
bleiben aber im himmelreich ja da sitzt
dann abrahams schoß
facebook ist aber harmlos für die armen
unserer zeit die menschen nicht reicher
also werden auch nicht mehr geliebt dass
sie haben auch nicht mehr
sozusagen soziale anerkennung in der in
der realen welt aber in der fiktiven
welt in der virtuellen welt was ist
religion anderer ist als virtualität der
in der virtuellen welt sammeln sich
sterne um sternen um stern gratulation
wunderbar alle sind zufrieden und die
dinge können weiter so laufen wie sie
laufen sollen
sollten sie noch kurz darauf legen hier
was so der soziologe sonst sagen also
sagen unterschätzen sie die gesellschaft
nicht die ist stabiler als man so denkt
die schichtung der gesellschaft des
stabiler als man denkt die verteilung
von lebenschancen ist über die letzten
generation viel weniger verändert worden
als wir so genannten das entstehen aber
neue akteure die mächtig sind wir haben
von facebook gerade gesprochen
denken sie an google denken sie an apple
denken sie an ganz andere firmen die
sozusagen in der lage sind heute mit
diesen ratings tatsächlich etwas zu
machen womit man viel geld verdienen
können wir jetzt so viel reisen
die lebensform der jungen leute in
kalifornien die einer ideologie haben
dass man sozusagen über diese ratings
das eigentlich ganz toll macht die
werden von diesem unternehmen rein
geholt und wieder raus geschrien wäre
eingeholt wird und sozusagen ein produkt
entwickelt hat es geschafft und wer
nicht wird rausgespielt man muss das gar
nicht kritisieren nicht toll finden
sondern das ist eine völlig neue form an
das erwähnen muss man auch dazu sagen
dass sie sich genau durch diese form von
digitalen ökonomie die lebenschancen von
jungen menschen im image qualitativ
gesehen ja eigentlich vermindern warum
weil solche firmen wird er sagen ihren
umsatz machen mit viel weniger
arbeitskräften als zum beispiel ein
klassischer autokonzern
das heißt also gerade die firmen die uns
so als erfolgreicher scheinen die auch
rein jetzt in absoluten zahlen gerechnet
die den höchsten börsenwert haben sind
jenen am allerwenigsten menschen
beschäftigen das heißt in so many meine
lebenschancen ab aber die illusion dabei
sein zu können
die nimmt zu wir sprechen als eigentlich
über die digitalisierung im allgemeinen
und deshalb nochmal der sängerin
zusammen das hängt damit zusammen aber
ich glaube dass genau das dass der punkt
dass ich kommen noch mal darauf zurück
was ich bei den jungen leuten gehört
habe ein satz den werde ich glaube ich
nie vergessen
ich möchte ein leben auch außerhalb von
social media führen
das fand ich ganz interessant und das
heißt eben wirklich dass wir lernen
damit umzugehen ich schwanke wirklich
sich in der disco
deshalb habe ich auch deshalb mag ich
auch geschichten und bücher die täglich
in die in das schwärzeste gehen und
trotzdem kann ich mich nicht gegen einen
gewissen optimismus wären gerade wegen
der konstanz der gesellschaften weil ich
glaube dass wir auf die dauer eben doch
lernen damit umzugehen und doch
regierungen schaffen werden und doch
grenzen setzen werden damit wir als
gesellschaft wieder sagen okay das ist
alles da aber am schluss sind es doch
wieder wie die sagen was ist denn für
uns wichtig welchem rahmen setzen wir
welche kriterien sind wichtig und wie
gehen wir damit um wir lassen das nicht
einfach laufen
das ist eine these wir lassen das nicht
einfach laufen machen wir die
gegenbewegung blicken je nach china
denn wirklich gefährlich jetzt ja
eigentlich wenn rating systeme dazu
genutzt werden um eben im großen stil
umfassend zu überwachen und letztlich
eigentlich unser verhalten zu steuern
und genau das plant china mit seinem
sogenannten sozial kreditsystem dass ab
2020 umfassend einen citizens call eines
jeden bürgers etablieren soll und jeder
bürger wird sozusagen vermessen ist
genau eben nicht demokratisch und wird
genau auch nicht in eine demokratie
gemacht dass sich das ist der
entscheidende unterschied wir uns kurz
einen beitrag dazu
sie hing probiert sie aus die neue app
ehrliches shanghai einmal mit ihrer
identifikationsnummer und per
gesichtserkennung registriert gleicht
die app alle verfügbaren daten über sie
ab und spuckt dann ihren persönlichen
ehrlichkeit status aus gut die
zweitbeste von fünf möglichen kategorien
die kriterien dahinter unklar
ich habe nur eine grobe vorstellung
davon was meine bewertung beeinflusst
ich denke solange ich mich zum beispiel
an die verkehrsregeln halten und alle
meine rechnungen immer pünktlich
begleichen sollte alles gut bleiben aber
ich bekomme nicht die beste bewertung
keine ahnung warum
ehrliches shanghai ist eines von mehr
als 40 pilotprojekten in denen china
gerade etwas erprobt was ist sozial
kreditsystem nennt eine art landesweite
soziale bonitätsprüfung
noch steckt die entwicklung in den
kinderschuhen doch das ziel dahinter hat
die regierung bereits klar definiert bis
zum jahr 2020 soll die digitale
bewertung jedes einzelnen wirklichkeit
werden
an der uni peking gibt es gar einen
eigenen forschungsbereich dafür hier
betonen sie es gehe vor allem darum den
handel sicherer zu machen betrüger zu
identifizieren
china hat sich in kurzer zeit rasend
schnell entwickelt von einem agrar start
zu einer modernen wirtschaftsmacht die
entwicklung der charakterlichen qualität
der gesellschaft konnte da nicht
mithalten
charakterliche qualität bei der app
ehrliches shanghai fließt nicht nur die
zahlungsmoral in die beurteilung ein
sondern auch ob man sich an gesetze hält
und was gesetz ist das definiert in
china allein die partei kritiker wie der
schriftsteller meldung zu ihr zu
befürchten daher auch dass die regierung
mit dem sozial kreditsystem in wahrheit
vor allem unliebsames verhalten und
unerwünschte äußerungen unterdrücken
will
china hat das schier unmögliche
geschafft das hat das internet unter
kontrolle gebracht und mehr noch die
regierung macht es sich zu nutzen
sie macht es zu einem werkzeug in ihren
händen nutzt es für eine noch
intensivere kontrolle der bürger und der
ganzen gesellschaft mehr als 730
millionen chinesen sind online zahlen
selbst auf kleinsten märkten fast nur
noch mit dem smartphone hinterlassen
unmengen von daten für den kontroll
würdigen start bietet das ungeahnte neue
möglichkeiten und auch das bestrafen von
unerwünschtem verhalten wird durch das
sozial kreditsystem einfacher und
subtiler
in schanghai beispielsweise werden guten
de autofahrer schon jetzt mit ihrem
nummernschild an eine art digitalen
pranger gestellt künftig drohen ihnen
wohl auch abzüge beim kredit stand und
wer zu tief rutscht muss mit
einschränkungen rechnen darf zum
beispiel keine flüge mehr buchen oder
bekommt probleme beim autokauf
damit hängt die kontrolle der
gesellschaft nicht mehr davon ab wie
viele waffen das regime hat oder wie
viel polizei
es reicht vielmehr ein klima permanenter
angst vor strafen zu schaffen
dielingen gegen genießt die vorteile
ihres guten ratings bekommt ein neues
weiß für die bücherei ohne pfand zu
hinterlegen
eigentlich wollte ich die app wieder
löschen
aber das fand ich jetzt ganz praktisch
also vielleicht behalte ich sie doch
noch hat die bahn die app ist freiwillig
doch eröffnen sich china hier gerade
völlig neue möglichkeiten die eigene
bevölkerung mit hilfe von big data noch
stärker unter kontrolle zu bringen
unwahrscheinlich dass das regime sich
diese chance entgehen lässt
ja ich stehe jetzt bei professor florian
als professor für informations und
kommunikations recht an der universität
zürich helfen heißt ein solches sozial
kreditsystem in der schweiz möglich wie
es im kino etabliert wird ja ich glaube
nicht das ist relativ eindeutig aus
verschiedenen gründen das system dass
china aufziehen will basiert einig
darauf dass das ganz unterschiedlichen
quellen daten gesammelt und dann
kombiniert werden um dann analysen
schlussfolgerung daraus zu ziehen und
konsequenzen abzuleiten für die bürger
bei uns muss sich der staat auch ans
datenschutzgesetz houten das bedeutet
der staat auf eigentlich nur daten
bearbeiten wir eine klare gesetzliche
grundlage vorhanden ist das bedeutet die
datenbearbeitung funktioniert eigentlich
in silos und die daten dürften nicht
über die silos hinaus beliebig
miteinander kombiniert werden also sagen
zusammenziehen und dann eine art rating
des bürgers zu etablieren das geht
eigentlich nicht und ich gehe auch davon
aus es gibt glaube ich weniger anzeichen
die dagegen sprechen dass der staat sich
wirklich auch an diese vorgaben hält
aber wir könnten ja die gesetze ändern
sicher das tun wir auch auf europäischer
ebene beispielsweise wird das
datenschutzrecht verstärkt die schweiz
geht auch in diese richtung zieht mit
dass ich glaube es geht eher in richtung
stärkere sektion für den status weniger
und wie soll das denn aussehen nicht ein
wir haben viele wirtschaftsbeziehungen
mit china
man wächst immer stärker zusammen da
scheinen ja wirklich ganz
unterschiedliche vorstellungen des
privaten eigentlich im raum zu stehen ja
das ist sicher richtig das ist zum einen
zum bezug auf china es ist aber auch so
mit bezug auf die usa aber noch mal ein
ganz anderes verständnis von von privacy
von datenschutz besteht wo die
gesetzgebung noch viel lockerer ist als
bei uns
also hier prallen schon kulturen
aufeinander die sehr unterschiedlich
sind solange sie aber jetzt hier um die
konkrete situation geht was der staat
eigentlich mit den daten macht gehe ich
davon aus dass sich der staat hier in
der schweiz die in eigene gesetzgebung
hält das heißt was china mit daten macht
die kinder möglicherweise auch über uns
andere geschichten das dass die schweiz
ihr tun
jetzt sagen sie der staat darf das bei
uns nicht tun wie es zb mit den
krankenkassen es gibt ja verschiedene
krankenkassen bieten ab an
da kann man boni sammeln wenn man sich
irgendwie an gewichts vorgaben hält oder
sich bestimmter nähert oder gegen den
fitness abo läuft uns bei diesen
krankenkassen steht auf der website ganz
deutlich die daten werden gespeichert
und sie werden mit dem kundenprofilen
gemerkt darf man darf sich also
grundsätzlich gegen datenschutzrecht das
prinzip der einwilligung das heißt wenn
ich einverstanden bin mit seiner
bearbeitung an der person tat und das
setzt voraus dass sich informationen
darüber kriege was gemacht wird dann
darf diese bearbeitung auch vorgenommen
werden
im bezug auf das die krankenkassen
machen ist glaube ich zentral dass die
leute wirklich verstehen wie diese
systeme funktionieren dass sie sich
überlegen ob sie da mitmachen wollen
oder nicht von diesem bonus punkten
profitieren von tieferen prämien
profitieren wollen oder nicht
das kann man jetzt noch man kann noch
wählen ist es denkbar dass man auch
irgendwann nicht mehr kann
ja es nicht vollständig ausgeschlossen
das wird jetzt datenschutzrechtlich
einen fundamentalen wechsel bedeuten
eben weg von der einwilligung zwischen
ein zwangssystem
bezug auf die krankenkassen stellt sich
die frage ja wo will man hin
die straße muss der staat dafür sorgen
dass eine bestimmte grundversicherung
für alle besteht unabhängig von ihrem
rating im scoring der solche
krankenkassen haben autos ist die eine
differenzierung erlaubt ich möchte ihnen
eine frage ständig nachher am tisch auch
diskutieren möchte nämlich im grunde
genommen könnte man noch fahren darf
viel von diesen social credit system da
in china lautet ja sozusagen die das
zumindest sie wollen gerne ehrliche
aufrichtige bürgerinnen und bürger das
ja eigentlich ein hehres ziel
erfahren sie dazu ja das mag das mag so
verkauft werden ich glaube das stichwort
das war vorher schon genannt in der
diskussion es geht eigentlich um
kontrolle um einen totalitären staat
versucht mit möglichst viel information
und konsequenzen daraus ableitet er
seine bürger zu kontrollieren hier
glaube ich in unserer gesellschaft
besteht dieses risiko kann
vielen dank
na ja es könnte man ja sagen wenn man
wirklich anständige ehrliche aufrichtige
bürger möchte warum nicht also herr
dougan hat jetzt gesagt das wird nicht
möglich sein aber jetzt aus
philosophischer perspektive warum nicht
gentinetta warum nicht wenn das resultat
weil und da würde ich eben schon wieder
zurück in die politische philosophie
gehen weil wir ja genau wie wir weil ich
jetzt die westlichen demokratien und
darauf hat herr dougan auch ganz klar
hingewiesen eben einen rechtsstaat
geschaffen haben und der rechtsstaat
legt fest was ist erlaubt was es nicht
erlaubt und was passiert welche strafe
wenn etwas quasi ein recht gebrochen
wird was war passiert in china ist
eigentlich der umfassende sittenwächter
schlechthin der dazu willkürlich ist und
wo der einzelne weiß und das kam bei
dieser bei diesem porträt der jungen
frau sehr gut heraus wie weiß eigentlich
gar nicht warum sie das beste und nicht
das bessere rating bekommt das heißt es
ist vollkommen unklar welche
willkürlicher autorität über mich
bewertet und was sie alles mit
einbezieht ich weiß es eigentlich nie
ich bin dem komplett ausgeliefert und
das ist und wenn dir genau das gegenteil
frequenz jetzt transparent wäre wenn ich
wüsste was ich tun muss um das maximum
zu kriegen dann müsste ich dazu auch
noch wissen wann verlässt sich genau das
gesetz was ist die grenze ab wann ist
etwas strafbar oder nicht nicht nur wann
ist es besser oder weniger gut da sind
wir genau diesen bereich der das
strafgesetz eben regelt und das ist der
unterschied für mich ich sehe es ein
bisschen anders ich glaube dass das
weniger mit demokratischen und nicht
demokratischen politischen systeme zu
tun hat sondern china hat nur die
möglichkeit aufgrund seiner politischen
verfasstheit sozusagen die konsequenz
aus einer technologie zu ziehen die wir
früher oder später alle ziehen werden
und wir werden unseren rechtsstaat und
wir werden unsere sogenannte demokratie
natürlich diesen logischen die uns die
digitalisierung nahelegt früher oder
später anpassen das sind nämlich zwei
dinge die absolut verführerisch sind
daran und wo niemand wird nein sagen
können das eine ist wie sie das richtig
gesagt haben es ist offensichtlich jetzt
so einfach geworden die menschen zu
konditionieren uns zu erziehen das
richtige zu machen das gute zu machen
ehrlich zu sein keine fehler zu machen
keine übergriffe zu machen etc
wenn ich sie immer unter beobachtung
habe oder sie sich frei gelegt
beobachten lassen und sich alle diese
daten die sie jetzt ständig von sich
hergeben wenn es daten verbinden kann
warum soll ich das nicht zu einem guten
zweck nutzen das ist übrigens auch die
offizielle ideologie von google unter
mark zuckerberg
das heißt also die profitieren ja genau
das ende der privatheit erwartet kennen
sie nicht
und dieser blume sagt er wer ehrlich ist
hat nichts zu verbergen warum so der
seine daten geheim halten wollen und
dass ich überhaupt ausklinken wollen
dass diesen daten kontrollsystemen dann
hörten auch bei uns allen teilen ist das
eine und das andere es muss sich schon
fragen wo beginnt das dann okay ich gebe
freiwillige meine gesundheitsdaten
meiner versicherung ja damit sie eine
bessere prämie bekommen wenn ich brav
trainiert mich ständig kontrollieren das
richtige ist
was heißt das richtige essen das heißt
da gibt es ja völlig unterschiedliche
kontroversen auf und dann wird
entschieden er hat uns ganz bestimmte
meinungen entscheidenden führen diese
kriterien eines richtiges essen heißt
und dass wir zurück gespielt dafür eine
prämie
aber dann kommt der arbeitgeber und sagt
ich stehe ja auch daran interessiert
dass menschen die ich einstelle gesund
sind fragte versicherung können es nicht
die daten weil so rüber schaufeln ja was
spricht denn eigentlich dagegen ist doch
sinnvoll ist es nicht mehr interesse des
arbeitgebers
dann kommen andere institutionen das
heißt dass wächst aus sich heraus es ist
die logik dieses systems das heißt china
china führt uns unsere eigene zukunft
voraus ganz kurz völlig einzigartig
[Applaus]
einverstanden einverstanden was die
extrapolation der möglichkeiten angeht
völlig einfachen die frage ist nur
reagieren wir normativ darauf oder nicht
und da habe ich noch nicht ganz
aufgegeben
sie sehen was nicht widerstandsnester
dagegen ich sehe nicht denn aufschreiben
versicherungen solche modelle anbieten
ja ich sehe nicht die großen gestus der
verweigerung und beenden das heißt
normativ darauf zu reagieren wollen wir
als gesellschaft eben es einfach laufen
lassen oder nicht oder versuchen wir
mindestens mit rechts vorkehrungen und
so weiter dem einen gewissen einhalt zu
gebieten
ja ja das passiert ja das passiert jetzt
so weit aber eigentlich wie das ist ja
die spannende frage so der große
unterschied da wäre ich also bei herr
ließ man durchaus auch bei ihnen aber
der große unterschied ist ja dass in
china ist ein politischer akteur ist der
dass der treiber ist und bei uns sind
das private akteure oder sagen wir
ökonomische akteure
man weiß gar nicht mehr so genau worin
die sich eigentlich unterscheiden im
hinblick auf datenverarbeitung und
kontrolle also es ist nicht etwas völlig
neues damit bekommen auch normative
debatten eine völlig neue dimension weil
eine normative debatte setzt natürlich
auch die kontrollierbarkeit der
gesellschaft erstens durch
strafverfolgung und zweitens natürlich
auch durch die umsetzung von sagen wir
mal strafbewehrten normen in privates
verhalten voraus und das können wir
natürlich in dieser form nicht mehr
machen weil wir ja inzwischen ist er mit
datenspuren zu tun haben als mit einem
bewussten mit einer bewussten frage in
china möchte man das bewusstmachen und
spannender weise die leute auch
entsprechend einholen die haben
natürlich keine demokratische tradition
und können normativ dagegen viel
schwerer vorgeben aber sowas ähnliches
haben wir natürlich bei uns etwa in der
versicherungsbranche also und zwar
völlig ohne digitalisierung ich weiß
nicht wie es in der schweiz in
deutschland ist es so dass man
notwendigerweise wenn man die
versicherung als autofahrer wechselt die
die statistik ob man unfälle gebaut hat
oder nicht weitergegeben werden sonst
muss man bei 175 prozent neu beginnen
das heißt man hat etwas davon dass man
ehrlich ist also ehrlichkeit wäre
sozusagen hier durchaus eine art von
konform verhalten und wenn sie den
strafverfolgungsbehörden wirklich
auffällig werden wollen dann müssen sie
heute alles ohne
kreditkarte machen also bar bezahlen
oder analog das spannende ist um das
noch eben zu sagen dass die dass wir
nicht mehr wissen was das für eine art
von akteuren sind deshalb ist die
normative debatte natürlich eine schöne
normative debatte aber die
anknüpfungspunkte in die gesellschaft
der fehlten heimischen es scheint mir so
zu sein es gibt unterschiedliche gründe
warum man so ein system gruselig finden
kann und einer kann der nämlich sein
dass man denkt na ja wir sind ein
rechtsstaat
dazu gehört auch zum beispiel eine
gewisse minimale nur rechtliche
regulierung dessen was möglich ist aber
ansonsten bezüglich den werten den
lebenseinstellungen eine pluralistische
vorstellung zu haben und das ist
wahrscheinlich etwas worauf wir uns war
einigen könnten
aber es gibt ja noch andere kriterien
oder andere probleme und etwas auf mich
sehr beschäftigt ist dieses
denunziantentum was diesem system ja
auch inneren dass man denkt sofort an
die stasi weil das weiterspinnt wenn man
das liest was china geplant da geht
natürlich auch darum dass man den
nachbarn melden kann der dauernd sein
fahrrad am falschen ort passiert oder
der nachbar der den müll am falschen ort
entsorgt und das gibt dann auch wiederum
abzug im social credit system und ich
glaube eine gute die story die das
wirklich noch einmal sehr klar auf den
punkt bringt ist einerseits der roman
des circle der viel diskutiert worden
ist aber auf der anderen seite es gibt
sicher viele zuschauer zu schauen die
diese kennen bleibt mir eine britische
serie die in der dritten staffel eine
ganze episode diesem thema gewidmet
hatte man sieht wie die leute mit dem
handy umgehen und via gesichtserkennung
schwebt oberhalb der person sozusagen
immer der social score der sich sofort
verändert je nachdem wie man in der
interaktion miteinander ist ob man
irgendwie nette bilder postet oder nicht
und das scheint ja wirklich grauenhaft
zu sein wenn man auch so abhängig wird
von einander ja interessant ist dass es
ja da eine für mich eine deutliche
parallelität gibt zwischen dem was sie
eben beschrieben haben mit dem
menschlichen verhalten das passive alle
bereiche geht und der tatsache dass wir
im recht versuchen silos zu behalten
und was das scoring macht es vermischt
ja alles vermischt alle daten und in der
wahrnehmung werden alle verhaltensweisen
vermischt egal ob wirklich
eben strafrechtlich oder ob einfach so
ein bisschen unangenehm und das halte
ich wirklich für den gefährlichen für
die gefährlichen stichwort gruselig ja
ich weiß jetzt nicht was große liga ist
diese konzeption über diese vision diese
dystopie oder fürmann her wirklich eine
utopie also eher positiv und sehen das
darf man nicht vergessen oder eben die
art und weise wie das sich schleichend
durchsetzt ohne dass wir es eigentlich
so richtig bemerken wir führen diese
diskussion über öffentliche versus
privat zum beispiel gar nicht mehr
sollen es ist ausgemacht der dass man
bestimmte formen von privatheit von
privatleben von zurückgezogenheit
einfach nicht mehr zu leben hat dass man
daten preiszugeben hat dass man sich zu
offenbaren hat weil man eben nichts
verbergen soll nichts zu verbergen hat
wenn in china wie wir gesehen haben
autofahrer die gucken wo nicht zu fest
an einen virtuellen pranger gestellt
werden den haben wir durch diesen
virtuellen pranger haben wir doch in den
sozialen medien gegenwärtiger menschen
verurteilt vorverurteilt verlieren ihre
jobs ihre berufe ohne rechtsstaatliches
verfahren einfach aufgrund von
medienkampagnen und weil es dort um eine
sache geht die uns ganz ganz wichtig ist
stimmen wir auch sofort zu aber das will
ich entferne wird dich noch noch
besprechen was erstens was wir es den
heißen dagegen zu sein und zweitens gab
es denn schon einmal eine zeit in der
menschheitsgeschichte wo wir den
eindruck hatten wir rasseln faden gerade
in eine disco pierer ein die wir nicht
wollen und wir tun nichts gab es das
schon mal den buchdruck so eine
katastrophe ist das gewesen also und
zwar die katastrophe dafür dass man
einen wahnsinnigen kritik überschuss in
die gesellschaft genau das fanden viele
ziemlich blöd das war etwas wo wir auch
sagen würden wo führt das noch hin wenn
jeder jeder war damals jeder der
irgendwie zugang natürlich dazu hatte
dass man ein buch schreiben kann dass
man etwas gedrucktes hinterlassen wenn
jeder die heilige schrift kritisieren
kann wenn jeder in der lage ist die
heilige schrift anders auszulegen als
man das vorher gemacht hat und ich
glaube schon
also das ist jetzt nicht nur sozusagen
eine oberschule oder coole beschreibung
sozusagen einer historischen parallel
sondern ich glaube schon dass das in der
tat eine mischung von utopie und
dystopie gewesen ist weil man einfach
mit mustern zu tun hatte die völlig neu
funktionieren die zeitung ist was
ähnliches gewesen das radio ist was
ähnliches gewesen das radio hat vor
allem unter diktaturen zunächst einmal
ganz ganz toll funktioniert inzwischen
würden wir sagen wir hören man am besten
radio und pluralistische meinungen
rauszukriegen weil im fernsehen immer
die gleichen leute sind als wir sogar
[Gelächter]
wichtige heraus dass das wäre ja
eigentlich heißen ist alles in butter
sie würden ja dass wir den buchdruck
rückgängig machen nein ich würde auch
sagen dass wir diese ganze form von
digitalisierung und auch das rating und
mancher dieser geschichte nicht
rückgängig machen können aber es ist ja
durchaus möglich so was wie
gestaltungsmöglichkeiten zu finden und
das interessante ist dass gesellschaften
sich natürlich sowohl technisch als auch
in ihren strukturen verändert haben aber
eben auch die kontrollmöglichkeiten sich
verändert haben
ich meine die demokratie ist auch so ein
interessantes rating da gibt es also
eine möglichkeit dass eine partei 32,5
prozent bekommt die andere 17,6 meinen
die leute das eigentlich ehrlich wenn
sie an wenn sie in der wahlkabine das
machen also ich glaube es ehrlich gesagt
nicht wir wissen aus der wahlforschung
dass die leute vor allem das wählen
wovon sie glauben dass es ihnen am
meisten nützt unter uns gesagt es stimmt
gar nicht aber die glauben dass
zumindest würden wir das zurückdrehen
wollen nur weil das dann im perfekte
lösung ist wir würden sagen wir brauchen
den gebildeten bürger der das
entsprechend kann und würden uns
sozusagen versuchen revolutionär
anzupassen an etwas das wir nicht
beenden können wir können dieses rating
wir können das internet wir können big
data nicht stoppen
wir können aber durchaus versuchen mit
den mitteln der gesellschaft etwas damit
zu tun zum beispiel mit rechtlichen
mitteln aber das rechtlich heißt nie
sorry aber das heißt wie dass man
sozusagen eins zu eins das übersetzt das
strafrecht könnte ja eigentlich alle
kriminalitäts probleme lösen indem man
einfach sagt kriminalität sollte
verboten werden
spannender weise ist gibt es aber
trotzdem kriminalität nicht obwohl
sondern es gibt sozusagen die gesetzt
sich dagegen weil es die kriminalität
gibt und insofern haben wir die post an
die menge lag jetzt da nicht auch die
schwierigkeit oder die schwierigkeit
vielleicht einfach das phänomen hier
spricht der soziologe der sagt sorry wir
können die gesellschaft nicht
zurückdrehen
so ist es nun mal währenddessen die
philosophie als darauf pochen sie ihre
wir müssen schon uns darüber unterhalten
wo wir eigentlich hinwollen gestaltung
gebracht das ist das was ich vorher mit
normativ gemeint habe
und ich hätte jetzt genau auch die
parallele gemacht mit der demokratie
damals hat man auch gedacht jetzt ist
das sicher unmöglich wenn alle
mitentscheiden können das werden wir das
wird die katastrophe der gesellschaft
was haben wir gemacht was habt ihr
gesellschaft gemacht sie hat
institutionen geschaffen
sie hat gewaltenteilung checks and
balances und so weiter geschaffen um
sozusagen nicht einfach nur eine
einfache mehrheit oder den großen mob zu
haben punkt sondern eingebettet in eben
wieder kriterien institutionen rahmen
gesetzen und so weiter und das ist die
balance die geschaffen werden muss und
geschaffen der sich in jährlich
relativistischen ich bin ich muss
optimistisch bleiben weil sonst ist es
nicht schön in dieser welt realistisch
wenn sie haben ja vorhin eigentlich sein
diesen günther anders angehört appel und
das gefühl oder dieser philosoph der
wird es angesagt hat im system in der
technik innewohnt schon eine logik mich
interessiert es tatsächlich hier liegt
so etwas wie eine möglichkeit der
kontrolle und selbstkontrolle der
setzung für den soziologen jetzt
gesprochen der setzung sozusagen von
herrschaftsformen durch neue formen der
selbstkontrolle die ist kann man
notwendig machen menschen doktrinär zu
manipulieren sei es genügt ihnen nur
aufzuschneiden und sie tun schauen was
getan werden muss nach einem bestimmten
verständnis und dadurch haben wir genau
jetzt sondern auf einer anderen ebene
diese frage die sie vorher völlig zu
recht an geschnitten haben es geht nur
um mustererkennung sogar dass moral
debatten ersparen es geht um muster
können wie verhalten sich menschen und
so wie sie sie müssen schon damals haben
auf dem schluss kornherr liessmann
wir sind eigentlich mittendrin uns herr
nase guckt noch ganz besorgt euch ganz
kurz nach den schlusssatz von ihnen
lernen
also herr ließ man hat völlig recht ich
würde aber andere konsequenzen daraus
ziehen und ich würde die konsequenz
daraus ziehen also eine mischung und das
ist eigentlich ihre position aus
optimismus und pessimismus tatsächlich
zu haben ich glaube schon da
dass sich die dinge auch jenseits
unserer intention entwickeln vielleicht
brauchen heute mehr intelligenz ich
glaube dass manche der muster erkennungs
geschichte muss dabei helfen können
rauszukriegen wie so ein evolutionäres
muster läuft und dass wir doch jetzt
eine wundervolle form wo man die sache
halb normativ und halb deskriptive
nochmal eingefangen hätte hätte
konjunktive bleiben schön beim
konjunktiv
aber wir sind am ende dieses
stammtisches ganz herzlichen dank ja sie
können dieses gespräch jetzt diesmal
nicht bewerten aber sie können dieses
gespräch natürlich licon aber vielleicht
können sie sich die kleine subversion
mal eine woche lang überhaupt nichts zu
liken und nichts zu retten
es wäre schlecht für diese sendung aber
ich würde es ihnen gönnen vielleicht tun
sie das einfach mal ja und an dieser
stelle bedanke ich mich ganz herzlich
sie waren top gäste vielen dank alice
mann/frau gentinetta herner see dass sie
hier waren hier diskutiert haben danke
schön
[Musik]
und auf
nicole
hier seien
vielen dank auch ihnen zu hause für ihr
interesse jetzt geht's hier weiter mit
dem film babylon der dem räte
romanischen auf die spur geht und frau
wurde nämlich genau vor 80 jahren das
rätoromanische aus vierte landessprache
anerkannt zeit also dem romand ein
bisschen raum zu geben
nächste woche da die grüßt sich pro
fahrt und zwar mit daniel dennett daniel
dennett ist vielleicht der naturalist in
der philosophie der glaubt der mensch
sei nicht mehr auf ein material kaufen
wenn sie ihre illusionen loswerden
möchten dann schauten sie ein
jetzt aber eine schöne woche
[Applaus]
[Musik]